hey guys i'm off the grid for august and
here's fake native american elizabeth
warren doing something really stupid
well as you know this hasn't been
received well by everyone in congress
senator mitch mcconnell says that this
plan is a slap in the face to working
class families let me ask you what what
do you say to a family that says listen
i just spent years paying off my debt it
i didn't have the federal government
helping me out bailing me out and now i
may be doing just that for a family that
at some point may be earning more than i
do
look i'm not at all surprised that mitch
mcconnell is attacking this and the
reason he's attacking it is because it
is very very popular popular among
democrats independents republicans
popular and you know why
because i don't think there's anybody
left in america
who doesn't know somebody who isn't
struggling with student loan debt
um this has become a part of our country
now people for whom their only sin
was to want to try to get an education
and not be in a family that could afford
to write a check for it and what we're
saying is as a nation we can do better
than that we can invest in our people we
can help our people and ultimately what
the data show us
is that because of student loan debt
there are many people who don't move out
of their mama's basement who can't save
up money to buy a home
who don't start small businesses who
don't start a family
you relieve the debt burden some for
those people
and we have more economic activity in
other words
canceling student loan debt is good for
the people whose debt is cancelled but
it is also good for our economy and the
rest of america
this is yet another victory for for the
president and his supporters and as you
note
in your view for the rest of the country